très justement pour savoir ce que vous
êtes prête à faire par amour on va faire
une interview par amour en la bouche par
dans le qinghai
brasserie concentre toi on cherche un
jules est ce que vous êtes prête à
sacrifier votre carrière
par amour non bah ouais ah non mais ça
j'ai toujours été très bel accord
beaucoup pour les jours mais non mais
quand on quand on quand on aime on
respecte ce que l'autre fait bien sûr
mais mon métier c'est lui qui m'a fait
vivre et qui m'a sortie de pas mal de
choses que je lâcherai pas non est-ce
que par amour vous vous convertir à
l'islam
non parce que je crois que tout ce qui
est quelques religieux et qui empêche
l'épanouissement de l'amour etc me fait
plus ou moins peur parce que je trouve
que c'est dans l'extrême
je n'ai pas de jugement à porter là
dessus mais moi je pense que je ferai
pas
vous n'êtes pas croyante parce que ça le
problème peut-être peut-être je crois
que j'ai du mal à croire ans quand en
plus je vois tout ce qui se passe dans
le monde à cause des religions etc
moi j'ai un vrai problème est vite en
cause des religions sacoche des
extrémistes oui des extrémités
je suis d'accord avec vous mais bon en
tout cas la base est là et c'est vrai
que depuis depuis décidé des siècles
c'est comme ça non moi je crois en
quelque chose je crois au destin je
crois en une force quand une volonté en
plein de choses mais on est tous maîtres
de nos vies
et de nos destins et et puis voilà après
chaque lancé par amour oui prendriez 20
kg silva qui aiment les roses wahou
non non non non rien du tout à vous
droguez par amour non à héberger ses
parents par amour qu'il prendrait dans
les kilos c'est par amour mais j'aime et
ce que je veux pas apparemment je vais
je peux donner tous mes deux mois de ce
que je suis de ce que je connais un
amené à arrêter de fumer par exemple par
amour
rabastens et dire ça là par amour vous
accepteriez killing maîtresse m'a servi
un peu la question de la fidélité tout à
l'heure vous voulez mais tellement
voulais qu'il soit heureux vous êtes
d'accord pour qu'il ait une maîtresse le
pot qui semble souffrir super héros né
le voir aller ailleurs quoi ça me paraît
logique aux lillois 3 par amour j'ai pas
partager ouais vous êtes des problèmes
je comprends par amour je vous iriez
dans un club échangiste ça oui ça n'ont
suscité gens n'ont peut-être pour voir
mais je ne sais pas mais je comprends
que vous n'êtes toujours pas d'accord
voulais pas je voudrais pas parce que je
serai pas je serai pas à l'aise de là
dedans moi beaucoup d'amour non
sincèrement je pense pas que je serais à
l'aise au début mais je vous en prie je
vous n'êtes jamais allé jamais non mais
tout à fait voilà ce que vous êtes ça
mais sûrement peut-être mais en
attendant c'est résoudrait pas la
démarche de le faire je crois que je
serais choqué c'est mon mec me demandait
ça j'ai pas mal de vent
on discute
voilà quelques